Speaker 1: The Donald Trump indictment, which has
started as the Georgia grand jury is done. This is
a really big deal. And quite literally, any day a
Donald Trump indictment could be coming. Or maybe
not at all. We just don't know. The Associated
Press reports Georgia Grand Jury Ends Probe of
Trump and 2020 Election. The special grand jury in
Atlanta that has been investigating whether then
President Donald Trump and his allies committed
any crimes while trying to overturn his 2020 loss
in Georgia has finished its work, bringing the
case closer to possible criminal charges against
Trump and others. Further down, the decision
whether to seek an indictment from a regular
grand jury will be up to Fulton County District
Attorney Fani Willis. I thought it was funny,
someone told me. It's funny. I hope I'm getting
it right. Willis spokesperson Jeff DeSantis said
the office has no comment on the completion of
the panel's work. Mcburnie wrote In his order,
the special grand jury recommended its report
be made public. He's scheduled a hearing for
January 24 to determine whether all or part of the
report should be released and said the district
attorney's office and news outlets would be given
an opportunity to make arguments at that hearing.
Since June, there have been dozens of witnesses
and on and on and on in conjunction. Last month,
the House committee investigating the January six,
2021 insurrection asserted in its final report
that Trump criminally engaged in a multi-part
conspiracy to overturn the lawful results of the
2020 presidential election and failed to act to
stop his supporters from attacking the Capitol.
The report concluded that investigation as well.
This is a possible fork in the road. It's not
really a fork. It's actually a coming together.
Whatever the opposite of a fork is of the Georgia
investigation and the House investigation. And
we could see no charges. We could see charges
in Georgia, but not federally, federally and not
from Georgia. Or we could see charges from both.
And it will be absolutely wacky if we see any of
those combinations that involve charges. CNBC also
reports Georgia grand jury probing Trump for
2020 election Crimes Possible 2020 election
crimes Completes work. Trump also faces
a federal criminal investigation into his
attempt to overturn the 2020 election,
which he lost. One interesting note
from this article is where
is that interesting note?
Willis in January 2022, asked the chief judge
of Fulton County to consider her request
for him, paneling a special purpose grand
jury to investigate investigate potential
criminal interference in 2020. A majority of the
judges in the county approved the request. Okay,
so that's the critical line. Not every judge. So
even even as to whether this grand jury should
have been impaneled, there was not a unanimous
decision from the judges that made that decision.
And we should expect that similarly, there
will be dramatically different perspectives
on this at whatever the next step is. And it is
we can't definitively say that that's a result
of disagreements that are partizan in nature.
But remember this idea that judges merely take
the law and the facts and put them together
and out comes one and only one answer. We
regularly see disagreements and with something
as partizan and politically oriented as this,
we all know there is going to be partizanship
involved. Now, if Donald Trump is indicted,
it would create all sorts of chaos in the American
political landscape. Number one, he's a current
candidate for the presidential nomination for his
party. And the first question is what would be the
implications and the consequences for his campaign
for Donald Trump to be criminally indicted? Would
he have have to step down? And what does it mean
that he would have to? Would he have to legally
would he have to because of public opinion? What
what would that do to the Republican ticket? What
would it do to Ron DeSantis chances or would it
further open the door for someone other than Trump
and DeSantis? We just don't know. But it would be
very chaotic. Secondly, public reaction. We have
said many times before that Trump is basically
right when he says, I could shoot someone on
Fifth Avenue and not lose any support, or at least
he was right in 2016. Maybe that was also true
in 2020. Is that also going to be true in 2024?
Not totally clear to me. At the same time, there
are certainly followers of Trump who will see the
indictment as a political attack, or at least as a
politically motivated attack. It might engage them
further. It might unite in some way Republicans in
favor of Donald Trump. I just don't know. It's
unpredictable. And then finally, what would an
indictment of Trump mean for the future of the
country? And what I mean by that is there is this
tradition convention. It feels weird to use that
term, but there is a precedent and the tradition
of the DOJ not indicting sitting or former
presidents. And we have not seen criminal charges
against a former president. And so what would the
impact of that be on the country in the future if
such an indictment were to take place? So it
would be chaos. It would be chaos politically.
It would be chaos legally and it could be chaos
constitutionally. And it may all happen within a
few weeks. Or not at all or not at all. I am
still not convinced that charges are coming,
although I believe they are obviously warranted.
And I know most of you feel the same way.